talk to me about just like
what you've been doing over at no jumper
because i think
um
you know there's always
if you have a great personality if
you're comfortable on camera like i feel
like nowadays there's like no reason for
you to not
start a platform or you know i feel like
what you and ad are doing and do know is
special man like when did you realize
there was something
there where you're like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] could actually really work
damn i when they when the first one the
first time they brought me you know i'm
saying i was in my store on melrose and
and i was chilling and you know i'm just
doing my thing quietly because i was in
the industry for a long time but i just
felt like you know the industry is full
of [ __ ] fake certainly dumb ass
[ __ ] yeah so i'm like man i
ain't got time to be bothered that i'm
gonna just be over here
but call me he like man you want to do
this [ __ ] with a.d
[ __ ] show up you know what i'm saying
let me see what to see to do but that's
my [ __ ] pun though i've been knowing it
for a long time years 20 years of course
so i'm like [ __ ] all right you know what
i'm saying let me see what to do here
like yeah we thinking about um replacing
this girl that's on here you know she
kind of i don't know she it's iffy i'm
like whatever i'ma get on there i'm
gonna turn up for y'all whatever i think
it's just gonna be one day
i got in there [ __ ] the lights cut on
like they cut on in here and i'm like oh
this is crazy they like all right go
record i'm like we live all right cool
and it's just easy i'm just talking i'm
like you know what i'm saying it was
some little [ __ ] named baby young and i
just started interviewing you thinking
yeah yeah so i'm like what's up [ __ ]
where you from i'm like i don't even
know what's going on i wasn't trained to
do this this little mexican kid dude i'm
just going at it looking at me from the
side like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you got
going on i'm like
[ __ ] [ __ ] it you feel me like but
i just knew from that day on like this
is it
this is i'm like i could do this all day
anyway it just ain't being recorded yeah
oh god and playing like come back next
wednesday six i'm like
oh it's lit
and i'm like cool i'ma [ __ ] with it i go
back again i'm like this is easy money i
could do this all day this is what i'm
supposed to be doing talking [ __ ] yeah
that's what i'm supposed to be doing is
it hard cause even like uh i gotta like
i've been on three times two or three
times on the live show with some
capacity over there yeah and it's a lot
different than pre-recording
because you're live mm-hmm live so like
whatever you might [ __ ] around and
forget you're being like you're b like
it's live and everyone's watching you in
real time and let some [ __ ] fly and be
like [ __ ] that's the real training
though did did something like that have
to happen for you to like really kind of
be like
like did you let some [ __ ] fly that you
would kind of
um yeah i did they they kind of like
pre-war me on different things and this
[ __ ] i should say
like you know the lbtq community is a
little sensitive about little [ __ ] you
know because you know how we talk in the
ghetto whatever and i'll be like man
[ __ ] you that's gay right and they like
hold on don't say that oh something gay
yeah and i'm like whatever and that's
just my whole little thing [ __ ] you gay
like right and then they like uh we live
they had to tell me like we had to tell
me i'm like oh my bad lbtq i'm just you
know what i'm saying i don't even know
how to say this [ __ ] but i'm like oh my
god it's my bad
i'm gonna back my jeep yeah but yeah i
mean it's a couple times but not too but
not too crazy not too crazy